at the hospital right now is a man
fighting for his life after being shot
11 times
i'm michelle tavares the captain of
spring valley area command
i'm here to brief you today on the new
details we have on the shooting that
occurred at the shanghai taste
restaurant
located in chinatown
yesterday morning
it's imperative that you know that we
have the full force of lvmpd dedicated
to solving this crime
yesterday just before 3 a.m in the early
morning hours
we received a shot spotter notification
to our dispatch that detected 12 rounds
had been fired
simultaneously
we received a call to our dispatch from
the security guard in the plaza
that security guard stated he found a
male down on the ground in front of
shanghai taste restaurant
officers responded they located our
victim down on the ground with several
gunshot wounds
they rendered medical aid he was
ultimately transported to a local
hospital where he underwent surgery
today he is listed as being in stable
condition
we have video that shows the suspect
he appears to be wearing a blue jacket
white jogging pants with black socks
pulled up over top of them and he is
described as a thin build black male
he enters the business through the rear
is inside for about a minute and 45
seconds
and then exits again from the rear in a
northbound direction
currently we have nothing in our
investigation no evidence to lead us to
believe that this is a hate crime or
that anyone is specifically targeting
the asian community
during our investigation detectives have
uncovered a previously unreported
burglary that occurred about a week and
a half ago in the same complex
the details of this burglary are two
black males enter the business after
hours while employees are cleaning up
they go inside undetected steal a
backpack and exit out the rear door
again
given the fact that we have similar
suspect description similar mo and it
occurred in the same plaza we believe
these crimes are related
it is of the utmost importance that you
report all crimes that occur no matter
how small they might be
or how little you think they are
we understand that cultural differences
or a language barrier might result in
hesitation to report crimes
what we want you to know is that we are
here to help you
we lvmpd have interpreters that can help
ensure timely and accurate reporting of
all crimes
please remember that we can't help if we
don't know the crime occurred
there are several ways that you can
report a crime
if it's an emergency you can call 9-1-1
if it's a non-emergency we have our
non-emergency line 311
you can also respond to spring valley
area command we'll take a report for you
there that's located at 8445 eldora
avenue near sahara and durango
i'm sure many of you have already seen
an increase in patrol in
chinatown
you can wave down one of those officers
they're always there to help you
we need the community's help to solve
this crime
if you know of anyone else that has been
a victim or any other businesses that
have been victimized please we urge them
to call and report it
they can call us directly at
702-828-2639
if they'd like to remain anonymous they
can always call crime stoppers at
702-385-5555
sheriff joe lombardo has worked
tirelessly to maintain a great
partnership within our asian community
we need your help to report suspicious
activity
please if you see something say
something
we'd like to thank all of our community
partners especially those that were able
to attend here in person with us today
we can't do this without your help
with that i will take some questions
yes
we always work to have a large presence
within chinatown specifically we are
ensuring we're there until we can find
the suspect
we are in the very preliminary stages of
that investigation what i can tell you
is that burglary was discovered by our
detectives today they have since taken a
crime report for it and we are hoping to
release video to you regarding that at a
later date through the pio's office
can you give an idea of just other than
this particular
shooting incident but just give us in
general of how often do you respond to
this particular area
because looking at the
the crime map
it seems like
there's no violent
shootings at least within the last six
months
what i can tell you is that lvmpd as a
whole is down 11 in violent crime spring
valley area command specifically is down
13
within chinatown we've maintained a
rather consistent level of violent crime
we work constantly to ensure the safety
of all of our residents especially in
chinatown
that's correct
when the suspect enters the building did
he just immediately open fire on the
victim or did the victim have any
interaction with this individual is
there anything you can provide in
regards to those details we have no
video from inside the business at this
time
thank you guys i really appreciate your
time